[Music]
[Applause]
please tell me what's going on here our
group of friends has been playing the
same game of tag for 30 years what I
think people will be surprised at how
much how much heart there is in the film
a lot of comedies especially now are
broad or whatever and it's kind of hitch
over the head with all the stuff but I
think ours actually really explores kind
of the themes of friendship and and why
people will maintain relationships over
years and and what is it about to be you
know male friends and all this other
stuff and I think it's it's really it
really gets into that and I think it
really will surprise me yes yes I do
someone's gonna pop up style in which
Jeff Tomczyk you know directs the film I
think you're going in to see a buddy
comedy that you think there's gonna be
all sorts of everything that you've seen
before but stylistically his action
sequences are so big in every action
film like but what you can guarantee
yourself is a lot of laughs a lot of fun
a lot of heart it's a big stupid comedy
and I think the heart surprising
the game was really flipped you guys
connected do you guys do a lot of improv
in the film uh yeah to finance your
watches I don't know how to do that I
don't wear a watch
time is a construct varying degrees of
success actually a lot of times we do
stuff like this like off-camera and then
be like let's go do that in the shot and
then we go do it it's like yeah it
doesn't really work
this game has given us a reason to be in
each other's lives I think your dad
would have really wanted you to be yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you